all right jack i have a surprise for you
welcome and back everyone welcome back
everyone we're exactly where we left off
exactly nothing changed
okay jack behind you there's a surprise
really i hear you placing things
can i turn around now tell me turn
around i think you will like it
oh my god it's doors how did you know
how did you know i like doors i just
know irish people like doors right
yeah we love to be oppressed and stay
inside i'm already doing the accident
again
stop doing the accent jack
it's prison just like my mom used to
make
oh what was that what were you doing
nothing nothing today jack
we should try and aim for nether i feel
like it's time
oh we need to get obsidian but how we
get obsidian
let's ask what is she watersheep which
direction
you take door from water sheep oh sorry
he need door i need though okay
knock first knock knock knock knock
water sheep
he said yes okay he said he said yes
i'm trying to role play jack water sheep
where do we go
in our minecraft adventure today
[Music]
inside the treasure was inside all along
watershed what are you saying the
treasures in our hearts all along oh my
god so we built
down here so i have to go inside your
heart
so we dig straight down in minecraft
wait i'll i'll dig right next to you
okay whoever what have we got to lose
we are so good at minecraft everyone's
cringing right now
yeah everyone's like you're whoever dies
first eyes in real life
this minecrafter two people digging
straight hey i'm alive
hey my shift perfect
perfect now build redstone elevator all
the way back up
oh we can build a water elevator
actually yeah
we just need a magma block and some kelp
listen to this guy
i'll leave him for two episodes
he's teaching me her elevators
let's just search we've searched this
place already and we found
everything it has to offer oh what do we
have left
nothing let me get rid of my stamp i'm
going to get lost again
wait for me wait for me we're going to
find diamonds i lost
either no what are we doing jack
i don't know why are we so bad at this
when we play together
i don't know we can't coordinate
anything we're on level 28 now we need
to go much deeper
for diamond okay just dig straight down
straight no let's not destroy that let's
take a tunnel oh this is epic because
like we both take like one square place
each
right yes yes yes yes
of course tunnel we were already down
here we had a tunnel already
oh my god i want to
i need that oh oh oh oh oh i found him
so don't kill him don't kill don't kill
what's up kimo sabe
kimo sabe you know his name yeah that's
ki
we call him chemo for short because he
needs chemotherapy
no because he's this is short for kimo
sabe
you trap him in yeah well you have to
trap him
he's killing you dude
dude he's killing you he's killing you
like really well
on a scale from one to dead you're
almost that dead
why does he want me i don't know maybe
give him
give him flour i give him feather
oh wait i have torches oh my god
okay i built around you see you later
tiny villager i think he will despawn
but whatever
yeah see you later oh my god i almost
pushed you down ah
that's did you get it okay this is the
diamond floor it's cuz of water sheep
he saved us
oh my god where are we now uh we're on
26.
oh my god don't swore oh
i didn't swore
[Music]
i just said jawed okay i found the
red lava as opposed to the purple lava
yeah
you're you're a minecraft veteran let me
see you make obsidian
right now do it bro i want to see it i
can't do it without
a diamond oh i can still make it yeah of
course of course all right gamer
there's one one obsidian right there's
one right there
eight oh now there's two one becomes two
two becomes three
three becomes four four i think four
four
is that what follows of course they
didn't teach us math in ireland
they just teach you how to grow potatoes
okay diamond challenge
okay are we strip mining for this whole
episode okay yeah
okay you did you dig in that hole i'll
dig in this hole whoever finds diamonds
first wins
okay i have no torches but cool here
here's a cup
thank you shop shop shop hey no problem
shop shop and don't forget to shop
don't forget to shop he's cheating he's
going too fast i have to show jack
i can get diamonds before him no no it's
not real
i found iron does that count sorry steel
do you
call it iron two it is iron
oh it's iron ore then white steel
because you're the one who calls it
steel
oh i was like wow we're equally stupid
yes we sure are
come on diamonds don't be a boomer
diamonds
if i make if i combine redstone and
steel
and gold i get diamond there should be a
way to craft diamonds like come on
everyone knows you can make diamonds
yeah
just get coal and make a hydraulic press
yeah why can't just
compress it until it's diamond if you
can make a computer in minecraft
then why can i not make a hydraulic
press in minecraft
yeah nosh what the freaking deal i found
lava
did you find lava yeah we're at the same
hole so you found lava
yeah hi hello hi hello how are you i'm
good
i shoot arrow for no reason how are you
shop shop
shop shop bing bing boom this is
freaking
so that's your phone
oh it's so oh mine literally just broke
as well
wow we're so in sync hello boomer
hi boomer i follow
hello felix behind you it's a cracker
no man i actually can't get oh
i thought that i should
show up with hand wait how are we gonna
get out of here i don't
know how are we doing anything in this
game okay don't give up
we set up camp here okay you make
workbench
i make workbench and we go to work we
don't have any iron
uh do you not have iron i've ore oh you
made a furnace freaking
sweetness bro i don't know if you knew
this but you can you can make um
don't you dare say you can put wood in
it to burn
that was my thing's the only thing i
taught people
just because i taught people it by being
stupid does that mean you could take
this away from me
can you put door in lava oh my god don't
worry lava
what the heck wait i i have other door
well i'm going to get a push into the
lap don't go in the lava
now i can mine underneath the door where
are trixie little hobbits
i'm not a hobbit i'm tall so tall
thanks bro okay i'm gonna find more
diamonds now
i hate mining diamonds in minecraft why
it's the most fun when you find them you
go wow
like wow who knew who knew they were one
block away all this time
and i was digging four blocks in the
wrong direction come on let's do it we
can do it
positive attitude follow me i'll go a
different direction now
oh i walked by a diamond earlier oh my
god how many people in the comments were
mad at me
all this time wait wait how
how
[Applause]
no no it's good that's good this is good
i have four so we should go up again
no actually we can make we can make one
just make one and get the obsidian wait
here you go here you go
chop chop shape show can we put diamonds
in the furnace to make more diamonds
i don't think anyone's ever tried it so
let's see oh
diamond wow we spawned fifth boss of
minecraft
no one's been dumb enough to try it
i was like of course it doesn't work
only a boomer would try that
hey yay
or bat it died like sadness died like
sad boy
oh god i forgot how boring this is
without the enchant the diamond
do you have 48 weeks wait how many do we
need one two
uh eight ten eight ten ten ten
oh something burned i can't believe i
walked by diamond right at the beginning
jack oh mining diamond so boring also
jack
okay i did not find any gravel earlier
man getting flint's socks in this game
as well
oh my god you know what sucks jack
my attitude right now oh my god how did
you know how could you possibly have
known
no i i heard it i heard it all i'm doing
is complaining you know what this is
great
felix creeper they're super rare
okay we team up i smack where
okay where did he blow i didn't sleep
right in front of me and did
nothing nothing exploded what a pathetic
creeper
oh this diamond is so nice jack oh wow
oh it sucks so you don't have one it's
okay you deserve it you deserve it
why are you so nice you're a good person
uh-huh you're good at minecraft oh
and i'll mess it all up so
you did find the diamonds okay
eventually
i think it's because i like i stick to
the blocks and i'm just like okay bang
bang bang go go go
bing bing bong no i didn't thought you
were norwegian for a second
oh here's a spawner careful careful
it's poison spiders i break whip
just put the thing on top of it no no it
was still spawned it was just fun be
careful
okay okay okay
what okay don't worry i have protections
don't worry
i kill okay maybe not maybe i die
oh god oh god oh god i'm stuck in webs
they're fighting each other
what are you doing i'm stuck down here
oh god i'm the worst
use your sword use your sword
oh my gosh i hate myself
let's go just go we're going to the
service
oh sorry so do you come here often
not really you know i just come for the
hot babes
and the singles in my area i come for
the blocky girls
and the blocky boys how how can i help
in this scenario you're
just digging and i'm sorry gravel
choke oh okay perfect get the
flame did i get any head okay i got one
flip
that's all you need baby you never
supposed to dig up right
felix now it's not the time just
checking
okay we're at dirt oh yeah
yeah i see sunlight maybe
oh god whoa secret cave of mystery
what is watersheep doing what is
watershed he must
how are you not up yet i don't know
there we go
hey we're right by our base nice epic
let's put this
how many uh have we made
i don't know what you're trying to say
we made so many like random exits to the
caves
oh right i need food oh okay food back
here
um uh well we can make these freak
that's scary i didn't know she could do
that
now i have diamond pickaxe why is there
a hole in our
base because we just oh yeah straight
down
okay look no it's gone
should we see should we make a water
bucket and then we can just like go down
with the water
yeah can we acknowledge the fact that
watersheep actually got us diamonds
yeah let's talk about that now we go
down hold up
wait we got to sleep oh yes sleep sleep
next to sheep sleep sleep
i sleep now okay wait you have enough
obsidian what else do we need for flint
and we just need iron right
all right okay so we've won flint and
steel now at least yeah boom
there it is i put it in here because i
probably died
uh first i want to show you surprise
okay
surprise for me surprise for you follow
me okay
look at your tiny little legs though
they're so cute excuse me
look at your super long masculine legs
go okay so
just look at the top oh look at the
tower wow
look at that we built wow
i don't like this wow wow
oh it didn't blow oh wow that almost
killed me okay let's go
let's go
oh shoot i mean oh shoot this is
actually pretty
effective i didn't realize damn yeah i
have this in my in my regular base
going down into my irish bat cave just
saying oh okay i didn't ask but i'm glad
you're just saying
um do you want to keep digging in these
holes or go back to the other ones i
just want to
oh here's obsidian i just wanted to get
a couple more obsidian
careful careful i'm careful there's lava
right there
okay obsidian okay so we need eight more
this is this is fun so you might hear
often
i've been chipping away for a couple
years hey
i did a thing you did the irish bucket
challenge
so you know this game is old future kids
complain about
not having jobs
back in my day back in my day back in my
boomer days
we were ice bucket challenging like the
rat oh
there's no lava here that's very nice oh
careful lava lava lava careful careful
careful
oh oh sweet jesus
[Music]
okay i have five obsidian how many do
you have uh
17 my dude let's go lord okay i need to
seriously like food up before we go
anywhere yeah yeah yeah yeah
i see what you mean bro we should plant
some wheat we have wheat planted
oh we do we should plant more wheat i
like your thinking your brain is very
big
my brain might be very large you must
have at least 2 000 iqs
i have large oblongata oblongata
bro that dude i like to have this giant
hole in our porch now
okay wheatgrow this is good it adds
character
feed to uh them and let there be freaky
i put down granite instead of dirt
are you okay jack i don't know today is
just not my day
the pressure's way too high we found
diamond you're doing great bro
just sometimes i need a pep talk man
where should we put the nether portal
uh behind water sheep i was just about
to and i was like i don't know about
this
i feel like we should build it a little
bit on the side fine
because it's kind of loud too it's kind
of annoying when you hear it that's true
and we need to be able to sleep at night
sleep okay nice
so it's three wide right no no no no two
three why no you can just build like
this oh
oh look at him he's been playing
minecraft and now he thinks he's so much
better than me
you're doing it wrong
like this like this is
still wrong no no now it's right right
yeah
but you don't need that you don't need
this one in the corner oh
okay dude swore i mean it'll still
it'll still work it's just it's not
really efficient
is that it but it looks better how many
obsidian do you have
uh five okay i have five that's perfect
okay you ready this is epic moment
okay it's never before done in minecraft
ever
okay i press f1 so we have clearer view
what how did you do that
the nether's on fire in minecraft
what this hap ah okay what are you doing
i don't know
let's go there you go whoa three two one
go
bro
oh i'm empty i've got another with
another person
yeah me neither what if it actually
spits us out at two different locations
we need to go deeper jack oh wow
oh wow this is a horrible location awful
yeah
oh my god okay so at least the baby
can't get us
should we which direction should we go
south east
do you even know which one is which at
this point this is how
okay let's just go that way okay one one
side each let's go
god this diamond without the enchantment
it's like uh
dude don't use your diamond yet just use
iron i don't have one
oh wait okay why are you bullying me
i don't know okay i am not risking
anything this time
but yeah walking as i
yeah as i mine i've done that
oh my god my enchanted one when i had
like efficiency on it
oh we're out okay we're free sweet
no we should keep it straight keep it
straight just so like next time we
travel
it's easier but how far should we build
it should we stop it here how much did
we go
uh not really that far we should go
further we must go deeper
oh you're making it easy for me shut up
baby
shut up little leather baby
stupid creepy have you found another oh
was that your diamond
no have you found another castle yet i
have not that's
no don't talk to me
this has jacksepticeye death written all
over
there you two jumpy uh nope
i don't think gamers help gamers so if
you hold
if you double click shift it works extra
good i'm not trusting
anything hilarious
you fell for that old i'm even crouching
as i go just so i don't fall into a hole
run down run run throw your stuff
down it's okay it's okay i'm coming
straight back i'm coming straight back
gamer
i'm coming back i got your diamond
pickaxe you're fine okay thank you thank
you thank you
i told you oh i just crouch as i go
the nether hates me dude
it's the irish in the netherlands it
don't work it don't work
i was just there in the netherlands
people were so nice and tall
ah oh i thought i could trick you hi
i'm right here you know thank you for
saving me things ah we lost the obsidian
though
oh crap uh crud i believe it's the word
you're looking for
crikey ah crake okay so maybe this time
like don't hug the wall
yeah maybe this time i should just not
be stupid
why you put down torch i don't have uh
torches
okay i think we're at the end of our
whoa that is uh this is some dark souls
stuff baby
yeah oh there's pigment down there you
want to keep going
yeah let's keep going okay how about
this you either i keep going or you keep
going and then i'll get the obsidian or
vice versa okay i'll keep going okay you
sure
yes we can still talk right i think so
it's i thought minecraft was proximity
chat though i am i am
i am afraid to type i like how i made
you do this i'm like yeah you
uh you the guy who the guy who died from
doing this yeah you do it
oh my god there's like a super cool
plateau out there okay i just need one
more and then i'm there
oh i see the gas okay shoot him shoot
him with irish potato
i he literally lost everything felix
i'm running back not to be getting
scoured as soon as he shoots me my
floor disappears no no that's an easter
egg don't worry
did you place wheat where am i
i place wheat in all the places that
wheat could be placed you can't put
wheat in my hand and tell me not to
plant wheat
you planted it where the pumpkin is
supposed to grow
you didn't say anything about pumpkins i
say it now
you can't just be like oh my pumpkins go
here i say it stop
okay
[Music]
hello friend what are you doing
nothing what what are you doing
we play a game run from sword look now
he's done
we have wheat soft potato
are you throwing eggs at me what do i do
to deserve such hardship in life
haven't the irish been oppressed enough
over the years yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
go to bed
all right oh i wake now wow power nap
really work
close your eyes you don't need to close
your eyes when you're sleeping
back to nether dude we have melon seeds
and we didn't plant melons
felix creeper
[Music]
please say oh man right now oh man
this is cool no see this guy right here
yeah oh my god he picked sheep
pink sheep pink sheep pink sheep pink
bed
pig sheep you have a black eye in
minecraft
i don't like this where it is right here
[Music]
look at this look at this dude look at
it look at
top of the that tia okay here we are
let's go game okay you're the one who
has a bow uh there was a bow back there
and i
actually didn't pick it up oh you want
to shoot the nether smother
yeah do you food fruit is for cowards
here eat this
or people who want to sprint hey my
mouth wasn't open
go do it again i don't have anymore
oh god now i'm not gonna get my protein
for today
i have one potato i'm not gonna get my
gains bro
make good use of it thanks bro what if
we uh
spawn in the new biome that has like
super many
duper roopers i mean i thought that that
was just a legend
a myth well this is cool oh god this is
scary
wait let's push them on bye
oh no oh no oh no
whoa that llama is oh oh rod jack
it's shooting oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
oh it disappeared i think it didn't
disappear because i ran away in a d
spawn
okay sorry pig man sorry oh god i'm so
nervous about falling off
maybe i should just crouch and do it
heavy bye-bye have a good night
they just disappeared the best part the
best part is that they're immune to fire
so they'll just be in the lava forever
no
do
you get scared from little tiny irishmen
that actually jump scare you yes because
i thought i was gonna get him pushed
down
oh okay wait we should be we should
build the thing here this is cool
right should we build up and put it on
top of that oh no
okay cool
i mean if you want that we can do it
yeah no not me either man like
i i just wanted to know if you wanted to
do it let's do it bro
no no it's not it's cool man i don't
have any material if you want to do it
we can do it
no it's fine dude it's whatever it's so
weird
all right here we go now we're building
it up here okay well that's not
intuitive don't don't push me off the
edge all right dude i ran out of
materials why did you want to build it
up here
okay shop shop wow you shop so good
i shop so good wait
that's not it i don't know what i'm
doing i'm so nervous that i forget me
my brain is just like don't fall and i
can't think of anything else
okay we're up do not do lava uh we can
use lava to lift
this why did i do that way
no
my brain oh your pickaxe is fine your
pickaxe is fine i don't know how but
it's fine
how do i get there i don't know
it's okay what is wrong with me i'm so
hungry and tired
i don't want to leave your pickaxe
because it might despawn okay
get the materials i should yeah i should
get some stuff back here to build
oh my gosh i can't believe it i was
doing it and everything and i was like
wait there's no way that that's going to
pour out and then it just started to
pour out
big red oh the biggest brain
okay i need to go get a snack in real
life because i'm legitimately starving
and i can't concentrate all right do
that bro
oh no no no
not like this
oh what did you do
at the end down there that was a
gasoline the only thing that made it
jack
was your pick diamond pickaxe and some
wood
oh my god so i can't build these
apparently so it's three up right
uh yeah oh god and then two on the side
oh god it's coming it's coming oh be
careful please be careful maybe
we could get him to let it oh god the
level is free
here we go all right gamer let's go
yeah what's gonna be on the other side
take me out of this place what's it
gonna be jack i don't know but mine's
not loading i'm just stuck in it
me neither it's probably because it's
online and it's a lot too large
whoa
okay it's actually kind of cute here
what you never played two for simulator
you know it's fun right i'm not supposed
to give my opinion
but give it a try and then you can tell
me if it's good or not not convinced yet
okay i'll cut you a deal the game is
available
for free and that's a great price